Hallo, guten Morgen. Mein Name ist Keisal Gökdas. Ich bin die zuständige Einstimpfüße.
Bevor wir zu Ihren Bescheiden kommen, lassen Sie mich ein paar Informationen über Sie notieren.
Okay. Wie heißen Sie das?
Mein Name ist Clara Tauber.
Könnten Sie Ihren Vor- und Nachnamen langsam und kurz rüchterieren?
Mein Vornamen ist Kavi Konrad Elvi Ludwig Avi Anton R. Richard Avi Anton.
Mein Nachname ist die Taube wie der Vogel.
Alles klar. Frau Tauber. Wie alt sind Sie, Frau Tauber?
Ich bin 48 Jahre alt.
Okay, wann genau sind Sie geboren?
Am 6. September 1974.
Okay, wie groß und wie schwer sind Sie?
Ich bin 74 groß und 96 Kilogramm.
Okay, was sind Sie von Beruf?
Ich bin Erzieherin.
Okay, wie ist Ihr Familienstand?
Ich bin verheiratet und habe eine Tochter.
Ja, sehr schön. Danke schön für die Informationen.
Ja, Frau Tauber, was kann ich für Sie tun? Welche Beschwerden haben Sie im Moment?
Also ich habe heute vor ungefähr 4-5 Stunden plötzlich Bauchschmerzen bekommen
und Übelkeit und musste mich auch erbrechen einmal.
Bauchschmerzen, Übelkeit und einmal einberuchen.
Ganz genau.
Okay, plötzlich. Wo sind die Schmerzen genau?
Also die sind hier bei mir so rechts, rechts im Oberbauch, aber auch so in der Mitte habe ich die auch.
Oberbauch auch in der Mitte.
Auch Rechtszeit.
Okay, ich verstehe.
Wie ich tag Ihre Schmerzen auf einer Schmerzkala von 1 bis 10, wobei 1 sehr leicht und 10 sehr starken Schmerzen entspricht.
Also das war am Anfang richtig schlimm, ich würde schon sagen 9.
Deswegen bin ich auch hier ins Krankenhaus gekommen.
Jetzt geht es wieder ungefähr, weil 6, 7 ungefähr.
6, 7 jetzt.
Und könnten Sie genau beschreiben, wie die Schmerzen sind?
Sind Sie eher dumpf, drückend, stechend?
Also die sind eher so stechend und kommen und gehen manchmal.
Also die sind manchmal fast gar nicht da, aber es ist eher so ein immer wiederkommendes Schmerz.
Ja, das ist ein richtig Ausdruck, genau.
Okay, und streilen die Schmerzen in irgendwohin aus?
Ja, ich würde sagen, ein bisschen im Rückenschmerzen habe ich auch, so ein Rückenschmerzen leicht.
Rückenschmerzen auch.
Okay.
Und fühlen Sie sich jetzt tippig?
Eigentlich nicht, ist in der diese Schmerzen tatsächlich.
Okay.
Ich habe so ein Völlegefühl habe ich eher so.
Ein Vollegefühl.
Früher haben Sie endlich beschwerden gehabt?
Hatten Sie oder endlich beschwerden gehabt?
Also eigentlich nicht, aber ich habe so vor 3 Tagen, habe ich schon mal diese Beschwerden gehabt.
Und dann sind die auch tatsächlich wieder weggegangen.
Und das hat aber ganz kurz angedauert, ein paar Minuten.
Und dann war es wieder weg.
Und da habe ich mir nichts gedacht.
Ich dachte, okay, es ist gekommen, gegangen.
Aber jetzt, heute, das war schon sehr, sehr starker.
Okay, ich verstehe.
Haben Sie etwas bemerkt, Ihre Schmerzen abhängig von Lebensmittel oder Nahrungsaufnahme
oder gibt es irgendwelche Auslöser für die Schmerzen?
Nein, eigentlich nicht.
Also es war jetzt, heute war es auch nach dem Frühstück gewesen,
nachdem wir mit den Kindern im Kindergarten gestern haben.
Und letztes Mal war das, glaube ich, auch nach dem Essen.
Aber ich erinnere mich nicht mehr daran.
Sie wissen nicht genau, ja?
Okay.
Und ja, das war es.
Und möchten Sie etwas hinzufügen?
Oder haben Sie andere Beschwerden?
Nein, deswegen bin ich hier.
Okay.
Und noch einige Fragen.
Hat sich Ihr Gewicht in der Zeit veränden?
Nein, ich war schon immer etwas karpulent und bin immer noch karpulent.
Schützen Sie in der Nacht?
Nein.
Okay, danke schön.
Und wie ist Ihr Albruchchen?
Das war, das ich ja gebrochen habe, das war normal.
Also das, was ich gegessen habe.
Essen Rest, können wir sagen.
Essen Rest, genau, kann man so sagen.
Okay, danke schön.
Jetzt würde ich andere Fragen stellen.
Leiden Sie an chronischen Erkrankungen?
Ich meine Bluthochdruck, Suckekrankheit oder Galenbilasen,
oder Galenbilasen Probleme.
Ich habe ein höhes Kolesterol.
Hat mir mein Haus gesagt, ich nehme Blutdrucktabletten ein.
Und ich habe auch etwas gegen eine Unterfunktion meiner Schilddrüse ein.
Ja.
Was nehmen Sie gegen die Schilddrüse und die Schilddrüse?
Ja, und Blutdruck habe ich auch.
Blutdruck, ne?
Ja, okay.
Genau.
Also, Sinn, was hat Ihnen für den Kolesterol ein?
Wie viel?
Ich glaube, das waren 20 Milligramm.
20 Milligramm, ein Eis, morgens oder was?
Nee, abends.
Abends sind das ein Ding.
Und Ältiroxin 75 für die Schilddrüse.
75 Milligramm, ja.
Und Ramipril und Bisoprolol, je 5 Milligramm, beides morgens einmal.
Das ist ein Mikro.
Gibt es andere Medikamente?
Nein, ich stimme ab und zu meine Ibuprofen oder so etwas ein.
Aber nichts besonderes.
Okay, wie viel?
Im ganzen Dosierung?
400.
Ich freu mich, dass ich draußen kaufen kann.
Okay, sind Sie schon einmal operiert worden?
Nein.
Sind Sie gegen Covid-19 geïbt?
Ja, ich bin folgt, wenn ich gehen möchte.
Ja, okay.
Das ist gut.
Gibt es in Ihrer Familie, ich meine Ihre Mutter, Vater und Geschwester,
wichtige Erkrankungen,
wie die Tochterung oder Böse hat, Krankheiten?
Ja, also mein Vater ist gestorben, meiner Leberversagen.
Leberversagen, das ist sehr schlecht.
Der ist recht jung verstorben mit 55 Jahre alt.
Ja, okay.
Meine Mutter lebt noch.
Gibt es irgendwelche Probleme?
Ja, die hat auch Blutdruck.
Die hat auch einen leichten Zucker, ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher.
Aber die ist noch recht fit eigentlich.
Okay, das ist gut.
Haben Sie eine Schwester?
Ich habe eine Schwester.
Ist sie gesund?
Ja.
Frau Thauber, besuchen Sie oder gehen Sie regiermäßig zum Frauenarzt?
Einmal im Jahr.
Was war das letzte Besuch?
Wann oder was?
Entschuldigung, wann?
Das war jetzt vor kurzem September gewesen.
Was war alles in Ordnung?
Sie hat nichts gesagt.
Gibt es irgendwelche Probleme bei der Monatsblutung?
Nein, alles in Ordnung.
Oder irgendwelche, ja, ja, nichts, keine Probleme.
Alles wie es immer ist.
Okay, danke schön.
Schlafen Sie gut, Frau Thauber?
Ja, also auf abgebrochen, aber kann mich nicht beklagen.
Okay, wie ist Ihr Appetit?
Gut, zu viel.
Ja, okay.
Und haben Sie Probleme mit deinem Zugang oder beim Wasserlassen?
Nein, eigentlich nicht.
Das Kiva habe ich schon gefragt, aber Sie haben nicht Ihre Köpferkontaktur gemessen?
Nein, habe ich nicht gemessen.
Ich habe nur diese sehr starken Schmerzen und bin ein bisschen besorgt,
auch weil mein Vater hat ja auch Leberkrebs gehabt.
Deswegen bin ich jetzt hier.
Also der hat ein Leberversagen gehabt, nachdem er Leberkrebs gehabt hat.
Das habe ich gerade vergessen zu erwähnen.
Ja, okay, ich verstehe Ihre Sturken, ja, aber ich empfehle Ihnen positiv.
Sie denken positiv, ja, zuerst.
Das kann auch andere Ursachen sein.
Was glauben Sie denn, was es sein könnte?
Ja, Ihre Besperrten, deuten am Hersten auf irgendwelche Probleme,
Gallenblase, das kann sein.
Gallenblase, okay, nicht Geber.
Ja, Gallenblase und Leber sind sehr ähnlich,
aber ich denke zuerst Gallenblase-Probleme.
Natürlich würden wir ein paar Untersuchungen durchführen.
Dann können wir besser nochmal mit Ihnen über Ihre Besperrten nochmal
und Ihre Ergebnisse nochmal sprechen, ja.
Also kann es doch auch Gallenblasenkrebs sein, oder?
Ja, Krebs, sehr früh etwas genau zu sagen.
Ja, zuerst Gallenblase-Entzündung oder Gallenblase-Steinleiden,
das kann möglich sein.
Ich dachte, es gibt nur Nierensteine, aber gibt es auch Gallensteine?
Ja, natürlich, Gallenstein gibt es auch.
Und Gallenblase-Probleme, das kann auch sein.
Muss es dann operiert werden?
Ja, zuerst, ja, es ist sehr früh etwas genau zu sagen.
Ich habe schon gesagt, aber ja, das kann auch eine Operation,
eine Berufs- oder Bedürfnis, eine Operation Bedürfnis,
möglich sein.
Wir brauchen eine Operation natürlich.
Zuerst empfehle ich Ihnen, Sie müssten, Sie seien,
oder Sie sind müssten, oder Sie sollten müssten sein.
Ich habe heute Morgen schon gefrühstückt.
Ja, okay, kein Problem.
Ja, jetzt, ab jetzt, ich empfehle Ihnen, nichts zu essen.
Okay.
Also werde ich heute noch operiert?
Ja, vielleicht, Sie haben sehr starke Schmerzen.
Wir messen Ihre Körper-Tempel-Tisch und ich würde gerne Sie
körperlich untersuchen, wann es möglich ist.
Ja, vielleicht brauchen wir eine Operation, aber das ist sehr
früh, ja, das ist sehr früh.
Das geht nicht ohne Operation, oder?
Ja, das kann auch möglich sein, aber wenn Sie eine Gallen-Bilasen-
Entzündung haben, ja, natürlich, wir sollten Ihre
Blutwerte oder ja, Ihre Abdomen überprüfen und kontrollieren.
Abdomen, was heißt das Abdomen?
Bauch, Ihre Bauch, ihre Bauch.
Mit dem Ultraschall zuerst würden wir Ihre Bauch-
Können Sie das hier machen oder muss ich dafür überlassen?
Nein, hier mache ich, gleichzeitig, nach der Unter-
suchung, nach der Unter-
suchung.
Operieren Sie mich dann oder operiert jemand anderes mich?
Ich bin nicht chirurgisch, deswegen andere Arzt
oder Ärzten.
Aber Sie haben chirurgisch im Haus?
Ja, wir haben.
Brosse, Krankenhaus, ja, deswegen.
Aber Sie gucken vorher ob es Gallen-Blasen-Krebs ist
oder wie machen Sie das jetzt?
Ja, zuerst natürlich ein paar Untersuchungen durchführen.
Vielleicht ich kann etwas erklären.
Zum Beispiel zuerst, ich würde gerne Sie-Körper-
nicht untersuchen, danach will ich abnehmen.
Leberweite, Nierenweite, normale Blutbild.
Und dann eine Bauch-
Ultraschall durchführen.
Ja, und wenn es nötig ist, es gibt auch eine andere
Möglichkeit, diagnostisch manchmal therapeutisch.
Das heißt, die ERCP.
Ja, das ist ein besonderer diagnostischer
Maßnahmen.
Und danach, wenn es nötig ist, eine Operation
auch können wir durchführen.
Okay.
Ja, dann bin ich mal gespannt.
Ich bin auch.
Okay.
Haben Kollegen andere Fragen?
Das ist nicht fertig.
Ich habe ein paar Fragen, Noxen und Allergien.
Kein Problem.
Ja, bitte schön.
Frau Taba.
Nein, ich habe keine Allergien.
Keine Allergien.
Oder Unfalltwicklerkeiten bei Ihnen?
Ist nicht bekannt bei mir.
Keine.
Schauen Sie, Frau Taba.
Selten, ganz selten.
Was meinen Sie?
Wie viele Zigaretten?
Waren Sie nicht vielleicht fünf, sechs Stück?
Nee, nicht pro Tag.
Im Jahr vielleicht.
Wenn meine Freundin da sind, dann vielleicht.
Vielleicht einfach, sie können aufhören, oder?
Nicht so viel.
Macht aber Spaß.
Macht aber schon Spaß manchmal.
Ja, okay.
Und trinken Sie Alkohol?
Am Wochenende.
Ab und zu am Wochenende.
Was trinken Sie gerne?
Wein und Bier.
Was wir da haben.
Okay.
Zum Beispiel ein, zwei Flächen Bier.
Ja, es kann schon mal mehr werden.
Am Wochenende, da gönnen wir uns schon mal mit meinem Mann zusammen.
Okay.
Aber wie viele Flächen können Sie genau sagen?
Nee, das ist immer unterschiedlich.
Halbe Flasche Wein vielleicht.
Ja, und ein, zwei Flaschen oder auch mehr.
Kommt immer drauf an.
Okay.
Das ist eine Routinefrage.
Haben Sie Kontakt mit dem Drogen?
Ich nehme keine Drogen.
Keine.
Okay.
Und haben Sie Probleme auf der Arbeit oder im Leben,
die Sie belasten?
Ich bin Erzieherin.
Ich habe immer Kontakt mit den Kindern.
Es ist schon anstrengend oft.
Aber ich mache meinen Job eigentlich gerne.
Also ich gehe gerne arbeiten.
Sehr schön.
Keine Probleme.
Okay.
Entschuldigung.
Frau Taber, ich habe alle wichtige Fragen gestellt.
Haben Sie Fragen an mich?
Oder würden Sie etwas hinzufügen?
Ja, wenn ich jetzt operiert werde,
wie lange muss ich hier bleiben?
Ich muss meine Arbeit geben, ob ich schreibe.
Ja, okay.
Ich bin mir nicht sicher, aber vielleicht natürlich ein paar
Tagen sollten Sie bei uns bleiben.
Kann ich dann direkt wieder arbeiten?
Oder muss ich?
Vielleicht, wir sollten zuerst krank schreiben.
Dann sollten Sie sich ausruhen.
Ein bisschen.
Dann können Sie nochmal Ihre Arbeit machen.
Oder weitermachen.
Ja, und wenn irgendwelche Operation nötig ist,
können wir diese Operation leperoscopeisch.
Ja, das heißt nicht offene Operation.
Sondern durch einen kleinen Einschnitt führen wir diese
Operation.
Das heißt nicht große Eingriff.
Okay, haben Sie das schon öfters gemacht?
Ja, ja.
Wir machen öfter diese Operation.
Aber vielleicht muss ich auch nicht operiert werden?
Ja, natürlich.
Ich muss jetzt gucken, ja.
Vielleicht kann das nur ein paar Gallensteinleiden sein.
Und wir durch andere Methode oder Massnahme diese Gallensteinleiden
einfach entfernen.
Geben Sie mir den Schmerz?
Ja, natürlich.
Zuerst würden wir eine wenig Zugang ablegen.
Danach Schmerzmittel geben, ja.
Als Intrevenös in den Wehen.
Ja, das wäre super.
Aber zuerst würde ich natürlich körperlich,
Sie körperlich untersuchen.
Dann, Schritt by Schritt, können wir weitermachen.
Schritt für Schritt.
Okay, alles klar.
Okay, danke.
Jetzt fertig.
Haben Kollegen andere Fragen?
Ich konnte nicht hören,
welche Operation die Patientin hatte.
Keine Operation.
Am Anfang der Barschmerzen,
haben Sie einmal Zugang oder was?
Nein, nur ein Brochen einmal.
Heute Morgen.
Und jetzt noch keinen Schulgang gehabt.
Und ich war noch nicht Wasser lassen.
Gehen Wind ab.
Normal.
Können wir anfangen?
Ein paar Minuten brauche ich.
Ganz kurz, bitte schön.
Hallo, guten Morgen Herr Oberarzt.
Ich würde gerne eine neue Patientin vorstellen.
Hallo Frau Göckers, bitte schön.
Clara Tauber ist eine 48-jährige Patient.
Sie hat sich wegen plötlich aufgetretenen
politischen Arten,
Abdominal-Schmerzen im Epigastrum
und in der Nabelsregion vorgestellt.
Sie hat auch Nausea, oder sie klagt über auch Nausea
und Emesis.
Diese Schmerzen strahlen in den Rücken
ab und in den Rücken.
Sie leidet unter auch Methodismus.
Seit ungefähr 3 Tagen klagt sie über
ähnliche Beschwerden, aber heute sind diese
Beschwerden sehr stark geworden.
Ich muss noch kurz wiederholen.
Hat sie epigastrische Schmerzen in der Nabelsregion
in den Rücken ausstrahlen?
Nicht zeitlich, rechts oder links?
Sie hat rechtlich gesagt.
Sie ist keine B-Symptomatik.
Es gibt keine Auslöser
oder
eine Abhängigkeit.
Ankor Erkrankungen ist
Hypocholestrenämie und Hypotreuse
und Artilleriehypertonie bekannt.
Keine Operationen ist IA bekannt.
Im Status ist aktuell gegen Covid-19.
In ihrer Familienanalyse ergab sich
ihre Vater,
er ist an Leben insuffizienzverstorben.
Er war sehr jung, 55 Jahre alt.
Ihre Mutter leidet
und
Artilleriehypertone leitet.
Er leicht Diabetes.
Frau Analyse ist unaufgänglich.
Die vegetative Analyse ist unaufgänglich.
Die Medikamente
nimmt sie regermäßig.
Sie ist am Abend 20 mg.
Er trägt den 75 mg.
Ramipril und Biso Prol 5 mg.
Er trägt den 70 mg.
Ja, normalerweise, ich sollte untersuchen, aber habe ich noch nicht untersucht.
Haben Sie schon Schmerzmedikamente gegeben oder auch noch nicht?
Ja, ich habe eine Venösogang abgelegt.
Gelegt?
Und nicht abgelegt, gelegt.
Gelegt, einfach, okay, danke schön.
Gelegt, eine Venösogang gelegt und eine Schmerzmedikante gegeben.
Was haben Sie gegeben?
Was habe ich?
Nostroid?
Oder nie?
Novolgien, Novolgien, Buscopan.
Ah ja, Buscopan.
Metamizol, es ist Novolgien, Metamizol, genau.
So etwas können Sie geben in Pervenös.
Okay, damit Sie keine Schmerzen haben.
Ja, jetzt.
Am besten einmal parallel untersuchen und gleichzeitig Anamese machen.
Und wenn Sie mit Anamese fertig sind, dann können Sie direkt Schmerzmittel aufmachen lassen.
Nach der Glutantnahme.
Okay.
Als Nuchsen an Anamese.
Sie ist rauchig, aber sehr selten raucht sie.
5, 6 Zigaretten pro Jahr.
Und sie trinkt gerne Alkohol, Wein und Bier, besonders am Wochenende.
Aber sie erwarten nicht genau wie viel Flaschen oder wie viel Gläser trinkt sie.
Ja.
Und keine Allergien oder Unfallträglichkeiten bekannt.
Die anemlichste Angaben, die du tun am Ehesten auf, Kolesistitis hin.
Als Differenzialdiagnose kommen Kolei-Lyptiasis oder Akut-Pancreatitis.
Oder Kolesistia cartinoma.
Galenblasen cartinoma in Betracht.
Hat denn schon mal der Hausarzt ein Ultraschall gemacht, ist bei ihr ein Galensteinleiter bekannt?
Haben Sie es gefragt?
Ich habe nicht gefragt.
Aber sie hat schon gefragt, ob es Galenblasen Steinleiter gibt oder nicht.
Deswegen nehme ich an, sie hat keine Informationen über Galenblasensteinleiter.
Vielleicht würde eine Ultraschall nicht durchgeführt.
Okay, können Sie beim nächsten Mal nachfragen, ob das bekannt ist.
War sie denn im Ausland gewesen, in einem Urlaub gewesen?
Nein, aus Land habe ich nicht gefragt.
Und Wasserlast und Strugang waren normal, richtig?
Ja, ich habe schon gefragt.
Sie hat über Kulikatige Beschwerden geklagt?
Ja.
Kann es dann noch andere Differenzialdiagnosen geben, worauf man insbesondere bei Frauen achten muss?
Bei Frauen.
Ich überlege, es geht um atmische Schmerzen, aber oben.
Ja, die sind ja oben.
Nierenkolik kann es sein auch.
Woran müssen Sie bei Frauen und Oberbauchschmerzen immer mit dran denken, egal, was es ist?
Was müssen Sie auf jeden Fall, woran müssen Sie denken?
Oberbauchschmerzen und Oberbauchschmerzen.
Oberbauch und Frauen.
Bei jedem, auch bei Männern.
Ja, Schwangerschaft kann es auch sein, aber das passt nicht so ganz.
Ich denke ja, Oberbauchschmerzen kann auch manchmal ein Hinterfarkt sein.
Also Herzinfarkt.
Wenn man zurück in eine Schalt, müssen Sie eben ein EKG machen und ein Herzinfarkt ausschließen.
Das ist ganz wichtig.
Bei Frauen ist alles möglich.
Okay, gut.
Und was haben Sie jetzt vor mit der Dame?
Okay, meine Massnahmen, nach meiner Massnahmen.
Was machen Sie vor?
Ja, zuerst würde ich gerne die Patienten körperlich untersuchen, danach Blut abnehmen,
natürlich eine EKG schreiben.
Richtig, ganz wichtig.
Und eine Sonografie abdäumen durchführen.
Okay.
Wenn es nötig ist, können wir auch einen ERCP durchführen.
Nicht in der Notfallaufnahme.
Das macht man nicht in der Notfallaufnahme.
Sie müssen zuerst, bevor Sie eine ERCP erst mal anordnen oder aufschreiben,
erst mal die Diagnose sichern.
Die Patientin scheint jetzt recht korpulent zu sein.
96 Kilo, haben Sie gesagt.
Vielleicht können Sie die geilen Blase gar nicht sehen.
Manchmal ist es schwierig.
Was machen Sie dann?
CTTorax durchführen.
Nicht der Abdomen.
Können Sie CT-Abdomen machen?
Und dann können Sie die Diagnose eventuell sichern.
Gelingt auch nicht immer, aber manchmal.
Okay.
Sie haben jetzt die Diagnose nicht sichern können.
Sie sagen, es ist eine Schuld Zystittis oder Schuld Zystilitiasis,
wie Sie glauben.
Aber Sie können CT-Abdomen und nicht sehen.
Worauf warten Sie dann?
Woran machen Sie Ihre weitere Diagnose bzw.
Therapie abhängig?
Ja, CP.
Sie haben noch keine Steine gesehen.
Wann macht man eine ERCP?
Wir würden gelingt blase und Bauchspeicheldosen gangen,
besser beurteilen.
Wir machen eine ERCP.
Die Regel macht man eine ERCP oder eine MRCP.
Wir machen eine ERCP, eine ERCP.
Eine ERCP oder eine MRCP, eine ERCP,
wenn Sie die Diagnose gesichert haben.
Richtig.
Jetzt haben Sie die Patienten als Schmerzen.
Im Ultraschall können Sie die Gelingblase nicht sehen,
weil sie zu kompulent ist.
Und CT ist nicht möglich.
Oder Sie haben einen CT,
keine Steine sehen können.
Nein, Sie gucken erst mal die Laborwerte.
Ja, natürlich.
Was erwarten Sie im Labor?
Ja, Leberwerte.
Ich wurde überprüfen.
LDH, vielleicht.
CRP, vielleicht.
Was sind die Leberwerte?
Leberwerte?
Leberwerte sind nur GOT, GPT.
Was machen Sie noch?
Die Scholestaseparameter.
Was gehört dazu?
GOT, GPT, Gamma-GT,
et cetera.
Ja, genau.
CRP und LDH, auch wenn Sie jetzt im Labor
eine erhöhte Scholestaseparameter sehen,
dann kann man das auch machen.
Diese Untersuchung, die Sie gesagt haben.
Wenn man nicht sehen kann, aber eine Regel kann man im CT was sehen.
Ich wollte nur wissen,
woran Sie das abhängig machen, den Verlauf der Therapie.
Und geben Sie denn auch Antibiotikum?
Schon oder noch nicht?
Ja, es ist TITIS, deswegen ja.
Wenn es irgendwelche Entschuldungen gibt,
ja, natürlich sollte ich eine Antibiotikum sofort lieben.
Jetzt haben Sie die Patienten heute Sonntag.
Heute Sonntag.
Es ist kein Oberarzt im Haus.
Sie haben keinen, der die LCP machen kann.
Was machen Sie?
Eine Antibiotiktherapie.
Oder Analgitikum, auch Analgitikum.
Fangen wir an.
Und Sie sollten Müsten sein, ich denke.
Genau, richtig.
Und warten morgen ab.
Man kann meistens das auch morgen machen.
Meistens kann man das auch ein Tag später machen.
Also es muss nicht normal nicht sofort gemacht werden.
Es kommt immer auf die Situation.
Aber wenn Sie jetzt sehr hohe Werte haben,
zum Beispiel die Patientin des Geld, die Patientin hat ein CRP von
100 oder so, dann muss man das überlegen tatsächlich.
Ja.
Gut.
Ich glaube, wir haben das Wichtigste besprochen.
Wenn die Patientin jetzt gesagt hätte,
sie hätte dunklen Urin
und hellen Stuhlgang.
Dann haben wir das Wichtigste besprochen.
Es gibt auch eine Schollostase.
Wenn eine Schollodokollotiers besteht,
dann müssen Sie auch dran denken.
Aber die Patientin hat vermutlich nur in Anführungssicht
nur eine Schollostase.
Und die Patientin hat das Wichtigste besprochen.
Das ist eine Schollostase.
Das aber wird in Anführungssicht
nur eine Schollostate.
Es ist noch zum Beispiel dunklerin und hell painted.
Rosic получилось nicht.
Es ist ganz wichtig zu d pf advocacy,
aber haben Sie auch gemacht?
Vielleicht in diesem speziellen Fall nochmal nachf d fragen.
Wir haben Sie veränderte,
zum Beispiel beim Urin,
das Stuhlwebenwert.
sollte man auch mit nicht nur nach Durchfall oder Obstipation fragen, sondern auch nach der Farbe
fragen, um zu gucken, ob schon ein geilen Stau gesteht. Also eine Schollistase. Daran kann man
auch viel ableiten, an einem es sich. Ja, okay. Gibt es Fragen von den Mithörern? Ich habe schon gesagt,
aber wie viele Tagen sollte die Patienten stationär behandelt werden? Es kommt immer darauf an, wenn
sie zum Beispiel erhöhte Entzündungszeichen hat oder schon eine Selbstes hat oder muss
sie natürlich länger bleiben, weil sie antibiotisch intravenis behandelt werden muss. Ich würde
sagen, circa eine Woche. Bei elektiven Operationen, geilen Blasen, Entfernung, elektiv, das heißt,
sie können die Patienten einbestellen und sagen, wir machen morgen die Operation,
reichen meistens zwei Tage aus, zwei bis drei Tage. Aber bei so einer Patientin, es kommt immer auf die
Laborwert an, es kommt auf die Entzündungsparameter an, es kommt auf den klinischen Zustand der
Patienten an. Ich würde sagen, ungefähr eine Woche gibt es Fragen.